having just got back from ces i thought
the perfect tech tuesday video to do is
one that you guys have actually been
waiting for and tweeting me about this
is the new canon n2 digital camera a lot
of you guys know that i'm obsessed with
making sure that i have checked out the
latest small little consumer cameras
because this is what i vlog with i'm
always looking to either upgrade my
quality as far as video upgrade the
audio or have something that's small and
compact because a lot of us are always
on the go and you don't really want to
be carrying around a dslr or a massive
broadcast camera when you're trying to
get the shot the quality of these
cameras has increased significantly and
my favorite canon camera still to date
is the old canon sd 960. it was one of
my first vlogging cameras and it has a
very special place in my heart but today
we're talking about the n2 now this is
the n2 this is the just n essentially
the n1 i love the canon n series cameras
because they look really slick currently
this is my favorite vlogging camera this
is the n100 which i don't think i
actually ever did a review on it or did
i all of these also come in black so
that's an option in case you want
another color so doing a side-by-side
comparison of the n2 and the n1 the
first thing you're going to notice is
they made the lens black which i feel
like is kind of it's kind of distracting
because this one was silver and i think
it just kind of matched a little bit
better they also made the white it's
kind of like an off-white this one is
like a super pearly white along with the
other n100 details details the one major
upgrade with this camera
they took probably all of the advice and
uh criticism of people who probably
broke their cameras because they tried
to flip them up this one flips up and
what i like about this is it's kind of
weird because when i'm out filming and
vlogging and there's wind this actually
protects the wind from the microphone
because the microphone is right here on
top so not only will this act as
something that you'll be able to frame
your shot but it also is a wind
protector
magic the first time that i unboxed the
n i was like so excited and i went
i flipped this up and i tried to flip it
up all the way and almost broke this off
so it always seemed so weird to me i was
like you guys have this awesome camera
why would you stop here something that i
like about all of the n-series canon
cameras is they connect to wi-fi a lot
of times i'll be vlogging or taking
pictures because these have such better
zoom than your iphone you can connect it
to an app on your phone and get the
pictures and the videos directly on your
phone there's been several videos that
i've posted here where i have shot the
video here taken the video to my phone
edited an imovie and uploaded it so
getting into the actual camera itself i
made myself a note just so that i can
make sure i didn't mess it up the n2 is
a 16.8 megapixel for photos the n is
12.8 and the 100 is 13.3 this one has a
5x optical zoom and a 4x digital the n
8x optical and 4x digital wait let me
make sure okay yes i'm holding the right
ones the n2 has 8x and it doesn't have
any digital zoom which is is fine i
don't ever like to use digital zoom
because it ends up pixelating everything
so much so you guys can you can see
oh gosh you can see my messy room now
the only thing that i
might be a slight downside with this n2
and even the old school n it's not the
best in low light situations you'll
still be able to get the shot it'll
still look good if you do find yourself
shooting in low light situations this
n100 is
i love it it does such a good job of
auto adjusting this little guy doesn't
flip all the way up but what's cool
about this one i don't even know what
this video is about i i'm rambling about
three separate cameras so hopefully
you're able to keep this stuff straight
well this one has a
front and back facing camera so you're
able to film front and back at the same
time which is kind of cool i've used it
in various situations i'm sure you guys
have seen some videos here my favorite
thing about these smaller n series
cameras is you're able to charge them
with usb the n2 comes with a usb and a
little usb connector charger and 100
does not charge with usb first up we're
testing out the n2 here's our
video what do you guys think
okay here's the n series this is the
older version of the n2 what do you guys
think how is it here's the n100 video
test look at this looks great
so i haven't tested out taking many
photos with this yet but what i do like
is it's so simple when i first got this
one last year i could not figure out how
to take a picture you press down on the
top of this lens
um here's the top you can see the
microphone has now been moved to the
middle i like if they move the strap up
here to the top because sometimes this
would rattle and hit against there and
then the microphone would pick it up so
my first reaction is i was hoping that
the video quality would be a little bit
better than the previous version but
after checking out all of the canon
cameras that they have that are coming
out this year if they're not out already
i'm so excited because they have a lot
of really new features and i'm hoping to
get my hands on some so that i can show
them to you guys and i really like to be
able to show you how i use them because
a lot of you guys use them the same way
as i do whereas most people might just
be out taking photos and us vloggers we
use them a little differently than most
normal people and i like for them to
look good because we already look crazy
filming ourselves out in public so if
you have a cool looking camera
it makes it a little bit more cool
that's it guys i hope you enjoyed this
video i hope it helped you let me know
what vlogging cameras you guys are using
or what vlogging cameras your friends
use or if you're not a vlogger what
cameras are you using
that's it happy tech tuesday i'll see
you guys later
bye holy moly i just
said a lot of things i'm not sure what i
said